schauen wir auf das leben von gianni
versace vor 25 jahren da wird der
international gefeierte modedesigner
ermordet in seiner karriere bekleidete
filmstar sänger künstler elton john zum
beispiel madonna prinz eric clapton
sogar prinzessin diana hat seine
kreation getragen und auf seine
laufstegen standen unter anderem naomi
campell cadmos und auch claudia schiffer
luxus eleganz volle pracht gianni
versace ist der schöpfer einer mode
revolution doch alles kommt zu einem
abrupten ende zu früh grundlos
fünfzehnter juli 1997 ein warmer
nachmittag in mailand die
telefonleitungen sind überlastet aus
amerika kommt die furchtbare nachricht
ikone gianni versace ist tot
serienkiller andrew philippinen ermordet
dem modedesigner bei einem grausamen
amoklauf vw saß villa in miami florida
das motiv ist bis heute unklar was hat
den täter dazu gebracht gianni versace
zu töten wer war er ein rückblick
andrew philippinen geborenen kalifornien
ist ein hochbegabtes kind nach der
schule besuchte er die beliebtesten bars
und clubs der schwulenszene in san
francisco er sucht sich ältere liebhaber
durch sie bekommt er zugang zu partys
und der high society
ende april 1997 beginnt callboy zu
nennen seien schlachten seine opfer
männer zwischen 45 und 72 jahren alt bis
zum 9 mai ermordet er brutal vier männer
mit hammer säge baumschere pistolen
jedes mittel ist ihm recht nichts kann
seinen blutdurst stellen das fbi ist
verzweifelt nach dem vierten mord im mai
gerät der serienkiller auf die liste der
zehn meistbesuchten flüchtigen täter
er fährt mit einem geklauten pickup nach
florida und verschwindet doch seien
perfide appetit nach männern mittleren
alters führt ihn zu seinem nächsten
opfer
mode-ikone gianni versace ist zu der
zeit in miami kurz nach acht uhr morgens
verlässt er seine villa casa katharina
am ocean drive eleven sixteen in miami
beach kaufte sich einen kaffee to go und
läuft zurück hinter ihm killer queen
nennen die waffe in der hand er nähert
sich dem modedesigner und schießt ihm
zweimal in den kopf
versace liegt auf dem boden in einer
lache seines eigenen blutes neben ihm
sein ehemaliger lebensgefährte antonio
d'amico
am ende dieses krankhaften amoklaufs
flüchtet der killer und versteckt sich
auf einem hausboot am 23 juli findet das
fbi seine leiche selbstmord der
irrsinnige blutrausch eines psychopathen
hat ein ende
an der trauerfeier von versace nehmen
zahlreiche seiner freunde und kollegen
teil zum letzten abschied erscheinen
sting elton john naomi campell
prinzessin diana und viele mehr hunderte
weinen um den revolutionären designer
den mode könig die legende dessen erbe
noch heute lebt
jetzt liebe zuschauer haben wir ein
exklusiv interview mit dem ehemaligen
lebensgefährten von gianni versace mit
dem man gern der seite des modeschöpfers
bis zur letzten sekunde stand er wird
uns ganz intime einblicke in sein leben
mit gianni geben es ist eins der ganz
wenigen interviews die antonio d'amico
gibt denn mittlerweile ist er schwer
erkrankt uns gegenüber enthüllt wie das
leben an der seite der legende war ich
habe aufgehört die jahre zu zählen es
sind mehr die berichte in den magazinen
den zeitungen im fernsehen die diese
zeitspanne definieren für mich selbst
kann ich sagen dass diese 25 jahre so
sind als wäre es gestern erst gewesen
für mich ist jenny immer präsent das ist
ein teil von mir den man nicht trennen
kann
meine vergangenheit ist auch meine
gegenwart denn eine hälfte von mir ist
mit johnny gestorben das ist in
wirklichkeit eine ganze reihe von jahren
so gegangen dann hatte ich das glück
einen menschen zu treffen und heute sind
es schon 17 jahre dass er mein
lebensgefährte ist der teil von mir der
zusammen mit johnny gestorben ist ist
nun zwar tot aber nicht vergessen
johnny ist immer präsent auch zum
beispiel mit meinem lebensgefährten er
ist immer präsent ich spüre ihn er ist
noch um mich ich spreche mit ihm wende
mich an johnny da oben
menschlich gesehen waren wir einander
immer ziemlich ähnlich er war ein guter
mensch hatte herz für mich war es
dasselbe
sagen wir dass er mir ein spirituelles
vermächtnis in der arbeit hinterlassen
hat das sich auch auf die energie bezog
die er in die ganze familie steckte
genau wie in seiner arbeit
sicher jeder von uns ist da anders aber
mir hat er tatsächlich eine vision
hinterlassen